[Music]
this week we've been paying tribute to
the thousands of lives lost on september
11th which was 20 years ago tomorrow cbs
sunday morning's lee cowan shares his
essay about that day and remembers those
who did not come home and the loved ones
that they left behind
color
it was just one of the casualties of
that bright tuesday morning gray
became the shade of everything like
fresh fallen snow minus its tranquil
purity
journalists poets historians musicians
they've all tried to describe it but
words often fail in the face of pictures
we remember the images of the lucky who
got out
the honors given to those who didn't
and the words that made us feel just a
little less vulnerable and the people
who knocked these buildings down
will hear all of us soon
in the 20 years since that awful day
we've seen births and deaths marriages
divorces even wars come and go
the number of souls who remember 911 is
growing smaller like any great calamity
time
unwittingly throws dirt on the past and
there will come a time
when unearthing it will take some effort
but behind every memorial and the
crevices of every carved stone
are the ghosts of everything that
changed that day for generations to come
what is constant in the history of loss
is the reverence for sacrifice something
that isn't always voluntary for those
who survived
sacrifice is forced
and it is in their memory the
descendants of those who went to work
one day and never came home
to the sons and daughters of those who
rushed to the scene and never came home
the husbands and the wives of those who
were deployed
and never came home
it's for them
that we pause these 20 years on
just as much as we remember
those who were actually lost
it is so important lee cow and that was
beautifully beautifully done thank you
so much i